today on the mat wall show we're going
to discuss the sexually explicit
satanic new song from the rapper lil nas
x what makes it especially evil
is that he spent the last two years
carefully cultivating a following
of very young children so once again the
music industry
preys on kids also five headlines
including the trial of derek shoving
gets underway
joe biden says it's our patriotic duty
to wear masks and
the cdc director has basically an
emotional breakdown on tv
in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about the teacher who's caught on video
trying to racially brainwash a student
the video is
is pretty disturbing but important so
we'll play that all of that and more
today on the matt walsh show
the discussion around the new song and
video from lil nazex which
features the rapper sliding down to hell
on a stripper pole and
giving a lap dance to satan has mostly
focused on the allegedly shocking nature
of the content but there's nothing new
about a musical artist i use that term
loosely
resorting to satanic imagery in order to
generate publicity and controversy
guys like marilyn manson rob zombie you
know they would do it in the 90s
metal bands were doing it before them
ozzy osbourne was decapitating bats with
his teeth on stage
two decades before lil nazex was even
born
the fact that all of this stuff has been
done before doesn't make it any less
abhorrent
but it does make it banal and
uninteresting
we have we have reason to object to this
sort of material but no reason to be
shocked by it
is the point we also miss the point
if we're focused only on the content
itself as if it exists in a vacuum
if if lil na's x is blazing any new
trails
it's only because he's the first person
i think
to go this route less than a year after
performing with elmo on sesame street
[Music]
la la
now there he is on sesame street with
his uh with his first hit
old town road a song so bad that it
makes you long for the traditional
country stylings of you know luke bryan
lildnas
gained a large audience of very young
children
and this was no accident the rapper and
his
handlers made a decision to cultivate
this fan base with appearances on
children's television shows like you
just saw
performances at elementary schools they
even released a children's book
now in an appearance an appearance on
the view less than three months ago he
explicitly attributed his success to
children let's listen to that
well you know uh with the success of old
town road
you know majority of that success i
would like a tribute to
kids uh and they like they love this
song so much
and i this i didn't do a children's book
was bought brought to me and i was like
this makes perfect sense now around the
same time a headline
on npr's uh website also from
a few months ago reports quote little
nasdaq says children are his core
audience right now and that's okay well
turns out it's really not okay while
responding to the backlash on twitter
this week
the artist said that he um he quote had
nine months to plan this rollout and
brag that quote
y'all are not going to win talking about
his critics like me
now while while he deserves praise for
composing a mostly coherent tweet there
with correct punctuation a bar that he
doesn't often seem to reach
what this post really confirms is that
he and his record label were
very intentionally building his
kindergarten fan base
while also planning at the same time
this move into demonic and pornographic
territory
marilyn manson you know uh was wasn't
doing sing-alongs with elmo or appearing
on the view to talk about his children's
book three months before
antichrist superstar came out the record
industry along with hollywood
has always had designs on your children
we know that what makes this
notable right now is how incredibly
blatant it is
and how young their targets are
granted you know it's it's not the fault
of will nasa's or his record label
columbia records by the way if you
allowed
your five-year-old to listen to his
music on repeats
that doesn't get them off the hook the
fact that you shouldn't have allowed
them to prey on your kids
doesn't provide them a moral
justification for doing so
still it's worth noting the lyrics to
the song
that elementary schools invited little
nazex to come perform
here's part of the second verse it says
riding on a tractor
lean all in my bladder cheated on my
baby you can go and ask her
my life is a movie bull riding in
boobies
now not only is this the most
aggressively
stupid assemblage of words that the
english language has ever been forced to
endure
is also not exactly family friendly
i mean why were you letting your kids
sing this
he is after all singing about driving
his tractor while hopped up on cough
syrup and alcohol
after cheating on his significant other
if you let your third grader go around
singing the line
my life is a movie bull riding in
boobies
a significant amount of the blame has to
fall at your own feet
but this again does not excuse
the music industry predators who are
trying to remake your children in their
own image
as brain dead degenerates but it
it does provide a valuable learning
opportunity
the lesson is that the entertainment
industry
with rare exception is not on your side
it has its own notions about what sort
of person your child should be what
values he should hold
what ideas he should have how he should
speak what he should
what is what he should wear everything
who he should hang out with
how he should conduct himself and not
only has these plans for your kid
but it also possesses perhaps the most
powerful mechanism
for enacting them art you know even bad
art
moves people in ways that no other
medium can
which is why by the way it's also very
stupid when you hear even
conservatives who will look at something
like this and they'll say well
it's just a song what's the big deal
don't make a big deal out of it
just a song oh yeah that's right it's
it's it's only art it's only the number
one thing that moves and motivates
people that's all it is
it's it's it's it's it's something that
perhaps like nothing else can
can mold a you know your heart and your
mind
that's it no big deal
you morons now it's it's likely that
millions of children who are
subscribed to the little not little
nasdaq's youtube channel
um and allowed by foolish parents to use
youtube without supervision
it's likely that millions of them were
exposed to his satan lap dance video
over the weekend
which was put out without warning of
course no attempt made by
uh the rapper himself or the record
label
to warn anybody or say hey you know
we're we're making a move now into adult
territory
uh don't let your kid watch this if
they're subscribed to our youtube
channel probably unsubscribe
none of that of course youtube itself
puts parental filters on all kinds of
videos especially videos
that contain conservative political
opinions
but they didn't put one on the video
with the guy singing about performing
fellatio on another man while gyrating
on the devil's lap
now this doesn't mean when you think
about all these kids exposed to this
over the weekend um this doesn't mean
that all all of them are going to run
off and join
the satanic temple maybe some of them
will but it does mean
that they will be exposed and were
exposed
to depraved ideas and images that they
don't
understand and can't mentally filter
or process all they're going to know
is that the message is coming from their
favorite singer
the man who wrote that fun book and sang
that silly song on sesame street
and so it can't be that bad this is how
the grooming process works
and it's why you have to protect your
children from it
because nobody else will
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five hit lines i
want to tell you about our sponsors
ready wise
you never know what's going to happen
what emergency might have nobody knew
that
texas was going to lose power for
several days here at nashville we had
major flooding last week hard to predict
these kinds of things especially
especially you know you might know a few
days ahead of time you're not going to
know weeks and weeks and weeks ahead of
time
and that's why you need ready-wise ready
wise is the leader in emergency food
supplies
they've got emergency meals freeze-dried
fruits and vegetables for convenient
on-the-go nutrition they've also got
adventure meals for hiking camping and
other outdoor activities
ready-wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online and you can
have nutritious meals shipped directly
to your
door very quickly when preparing our
meals all you need
is four cups of water the water doesn't
even have to be fine hot you simply
pour the food into the water you stir
and cover after about 15 minutes
the meal is ready it is that simple some
meals can be prepared even directly in
the pouch
brady wise uses the finest ingredients
and latest food preparation technology
to ensure
optimal taste and freshness so you don't
have to sacrifice taste
but at the same time the main point here
is you got to be ready you don't know
what's going to happen
this week my listeners can get 10 off
readywise.com
when entering wall should check out or
by calling 855 475-3089 readywise is a
30-day
no questions asked return policy so
there's no risk in taking the initiative
to get you and your family prepared
today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y
dot com promo code walsh to get 10 off
all right so the uh derek chovin trial
got underway yesterday
in uh in minneapolis and not a lot of
it's just starting now so not a lot of
news really to come out of the trial
itself
um except that the continued
threats and there was more of this on
social media yesterday
some some bigger platforms bigger
accounts
um and we've seen this now for months it
explicitly threatening and saying if
this trial doesn't go the way we want
we're going to burn down the city again
which is why if if there was any real
interest here
in a fair trial at a minimum they would
have moved the trial to a different
place
because there's simply no way
that or or it would seem very unlikely
that derek chovin could get a fair trial
it'd be hard to find anywhere in the
country where you get one but certainly
not there
of all places this is this is the threat
now normally um when you've got people
threatening jurors
with with with harm whether to them
physically or to their communities
if they don't come to a certain verdict
like that's normally ground from
grounds for a mistrial that's what's
happening here
they say give us what we want or we're
going to burn down
the city and a bunch of other cities too
burn down by the way our own communities
give us what we want we're going to burn
our own neighborhoods to the ground
to show how concerned we are about
systemic racism
and it just it it just goes to show
again that uh what has been clear from
the beginning of course
is and that is that you know the left
the media
they are not at all interested in
[Music]
getting to the truth of the situation
they're not at all interested in justice
this isn't about george floyd it never
was
uh this certainly is not about police
brutality it was
never about police brutality if
if if the real if the concern here by
blm the media on the left
was police brutality and that's what
they were worried about and that's what
they were speaking out about
then um there are many clear
clear cases of police brutality that
have been caught on video
that they would be using to make their
point they would at least be protesting
over
but they don't you've heard me talk
about plenty of times
the case of daniel shaver but that
that case maybe there are so many things
that that discredit the blm has done so
much to discredit itself from the very
beginning
uh i mean the very first case really
that um
around which blm was born the michael
brown case
that that discredited right off the bat
because that was all false narrative and
michael brown was
um entirely guilty of trying to kill the
officer and brought his
his death on on his own self but any but
if there's if there's one other case we
wanted to look to
point to that would discredit blm and
prove what they're really about it's
it's it is uh the daniel schaefer case
because this was the guy in um i believe
it was in arizona
a white guy on video
in a hotel in a in a the
the hallway of a hotel um
crawling on his knees at the at the
commands
according to the commands of the police
officers there are
more than one place two or three police
officers in the hallway training guns on
him
telling him to get on his knees give him
all kinds of confusing instructions
first saying get on your knees put your
hands up
at one point telling them put your hands
up and then also crawl like how are you
supposed to crawl
while also having your hands up i don't
know how that's supposed to work
but daniel schafer has guns trained on
him and they're they're threatening to
shoot him multiple times saying we're
going to shoot you
and um and he's also been drinking which
that's not against a law to drink
in a hotel room and he's getting all
these instructions
and he tries to follow them he makes one
false move it's like a game of
simon says he makes one false move and
they shoot him dead
all on video the worst police shooting
that has ever been caught on tape i
think we can say that
there's no and then the officers in that
case
or the one officer anyway was acquitted
the only officer to be charged was
acquitted
the acquittal happened a couple of years
ago do you remember any riots in
response to that
blm was active by then had been active
for years
no riots there were a couple of
scattered protests no big major
headlines
most people don't know this guy's name
george floyd
he's got all the murals and everything
else
so why do they skip over that case
if you're concerned about police
brutality there you go
would make no sense to skip over that
well they skip it obviously because the
guy's white
and they don't care and they hate white
people they don't care if white people
die in fact they're probably happy
that he that he died and it's also not
about police brutality
at all right now derek chovin's
situation is
doesn't doesn't matter guilty or not he
is a representative
of of of of
white america really he's a he is now a
representative
of the perceived sins of whiteness
and they need him to pay a price not for
what he did
but on behalf of all evil white people
everywhere
and if he doesn't pay that price they're
gonna burn
the city and many other cities to the
ground okay number two
yesterday joe biden called on americans
to do their patriotic duty
which i think is that's an important
thing for presidents
to encourage americans to do
but our ideas now of what a patriotic
duty entails
those ideas have really changed let's
listen to joe biden i'm reiterating my
call for every governor
mayor and local leader to maintain and
reinstate the mass mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require mass as well
the failure to take this virus seriously
precisely what got us to this mess in
the first place
risks more cases more desks deaths
look as i do my part to accelerate the
vaccine distribution vaccinations
i need the american people to do their
part as well
mask up mask up it's a patriotic duty
it's the only way we ever
get back to normal to cheer together in
stadiums full of fans
to gather together on holidays again
safely
go to graduations weddings what is with
the whispering
please i need you to do your patriotic
duty he whispers he goes from
whispering to shouting at one point i
said i think he said something about
avoiding all the desks but he meant
death i think i picked up on that
words are slurring together as always
the vacant look in his eyes
but this is our patriotic duty now is to
uh obey
is to obey him that's what our patriotic
duty is to simply obey
what uh what we're told and to muzzle
ourselves when we're out in public
even though at this point hundreds
of millions of americans
are would be immune because either
they've got the vaccine or they've
already had the virus
so many many many millions when you go
out in public
and you're at walmart or whatever a
large
portion of the people there are immune
from the virus either because of prior
exposure or because they they had the
vaccine
yeah biden wants to reinstate the mass
mandate everywhere
now uh meanwhile harry leetman
at the la times he tweeted this
as we talk about vaccine passports right
there's a there's a move
by administrationist is thinking about
and stating this
uh harry liebman says vaccine passports
are a good idea among other things it
will single out this
the still large contingent of people who
refuse vaccines
who will now be foreclosed from doing a
lot of things their peers can do
that should help break the resistance
down
so not only do we all force you to wear
the mask but uh we're gonna break we're
gonna break you
that's that's the the language that's
being used we're to break you
um with public shaming and
foreclosing your opportunity to
participate in society if you don't get
the vaccine
i just love again how the uh bodily
autonomy argument
by the left has been totally abandoned
over the last year out the window
this completely got my body my choice
out the window now
now what we know is that they've thrown
it out the window
but when this is all passed and this is
all over whenever that is like 10 years
from now
they're going to go climb out the window
and grab the bodily autonomy argument
and drag it back inside
and start using it again and they'll get
away with it too
because a year from now or two years
from now or a decade from now whenever
we're past this
um and they start and they start doing
my body my choice bodily autonomy in
relation to abortion
and if you say hey wait a second what
are you just saying
oh that's what about ism you'll be
accused of what about isn't
you can't do a what about ism for some
reason
when you're saying okay you're making
this argument now
what about the argument you just made
five seconds ago
for some reason work that's considered a
cheap tactic and we're not supposed to
do that
now the way around it um
when i brought this up in the past i've
been told that that this is different
because um you know forcing someone to
get a vaccine
forcing to wear a mask yeah you're
forcing them to do something with their
own body but
it's it's all about making sure that you
don't harm
somebody else and so that's that's what
this is really about you can't they say
you can't use the my body my choice deal
because uh this is not about your body
it's about
someone else's body who you might harm
oh okay so in an abortion
when you
dismember the quote-unquote fetus is
that your own body or is that another
body
that you're harming i'm pretty sure
that's another body
so what you're telling us is that it's
okay sometimes
to require someone to do something with
their body
even to the extent of requiring them to
inject a substance into their body
it's okay to require that to mandate it
by law
for the sake of protecting another
person's body
huh well okay
you know what i would even take this
deal i i personally would
i would take this deal if we can all
agree
that from now on the my body my choice
uh argument
out the window you can't use it anymore
and that include that that's
includes abortion
so all right you could do the mask
mandate you could even do the vaccine
mandate but abortion
but you lose abortion
that's a deal i would take all right um
number three the new cdc director had
something of an emotional
breakdown on tv not not doing a lot to
help
women professionals all across the globe
with this performance but here she is
when i first started at cdc about two
months ago i made a promise to you
i would tell you the truth even if it
was not the news we wanted to hear
now is one of those times when i have to
share the truth and i have to hope
and trust you will listen i'm going to
pause here
i'm going to lose the script and i'm
going to reflect on the recurring
feeling
i have of impending you we have so much
to look forward to
so much promise and potential of where
we are
and so much reason for hope but right
now i'm scared
um i know what it's like as a physician
to stand in that patient room
downed gloved masked
shielded and to be the last person to
touch someone else's loved one because
their loved one couldn't be there
i know what it's like when you're the
physician when you're the healthcare
provider and you're worried that you
don't have the resources to take care of
the patients in front of you
i know that feeling of nausea when you
read the crisis standards of care
and you wonder whether they're going to
be enough ventilators to go around and
who's going to make that choice
and i know what it's like to pull up to
your hospital every day
and see the extra morgue sitting outside
i didn't know at the time when it was
when it would stop we didn't have the
science to tell
us we were just scared we have come
such a long way three
historic scientific breakthrough
vaccines
and we are rolling them out so very fast
so i'm speaking today not necessarily as
your cdc director or not only as your
cdc director
but as a wife as a mother as a daughter
to ask you to just please hold on a
little while longer
i so badly want to be done i know you
all so badly want to be done we are just
almost there but not quite yet
so they they just can't stand the fact
first of all that people are
the virus is receding and i think
they're not they can't stand that
because they can't stand the idea
they're going to lose a lot of the power
that they have a lot of prominence that
they have right now
um virus is receding millions of people
are
immune uh we're getting into the warmer
months
people are lots of people are feeling
better they want to they want to get out
they want to resume their lives
people like this this woman at cdc you
know she sees these images of
of americans walking outside enjoying
the sunshine and maybe they don't have a
mask
on god forbid they're at the beach
feeling like they're getting their life
back the kids are out again at the
playground
this isn't the case everywhere
unfortunately but more and more
and me i i see this and any and
hopefully you any normal well-adjusted
person you see this and you feel great
about it that's a
finally finally but uh cece director
joe biden dr fauci these people these
anti-human
bureaucrats they see it and it fills
them with rage
because they know that they're losing
their grip they're losing control
over people they don't like it and so
now she's on tv crying
and saying that she's scared and she has
a feeling of impending doom
as i said not not
not a great performance in terms of um
representing for
female professionals
saying she's scared in this impending
doom
it's receding we're getting past it
and you're talking about impending doom
they really can't they don't want to let
go they cannot let go
all right um let's see here's a story
out of australia where
they not only have to deal with
man-eating spiders
but they're going insane on top of it
just like everywhere else you know the
rest the rest of us are going crazy also
but at least we don't have the spiders
uh they've got both things to deal with
in australia here's the story there
let's watch
parents at a victorian school are
outraged after their sons were forced to
stand up at a school assembly and say
sorry
for sexism the boys at the college in
warner bull were told to apologize to
girls
for offensive behavior on behalf of
their gender
he said that he was made to stand up and
basically apologize it wasn't explained
properly
to the male students what they were
doing or why they were doing it
the school now admits while their
intentions were good they got it wrong
in this case
no actually i don't think the intentions
were good at all you were trying to
shame boys for being boys they had to
apologize on behalf of their own gender
this is the this is the collective
race-based and gender-based guilt
that is part of the leftist cult
one of the one of the the essential
foundational parts of their
religious cult of their doctrine
is the idea of collective guilt that's
that's based on on uh
it's it's sort of like their it's their
own version
their own perverse version of original
sin except in this case it's based on
race and it's based on gender
okay number five from the jerusalem post
that says earth is safe from a potential
calamity-causing asteroid for the next
100 years
according to nasa the announcement
clears up fears that had lingered since
2004
when the asteroid 9942 was identified as
one of the most hazardous potential
asteroids that could strike the planet
however
this has now been ruled out thanks to a
growing understanding of how the
asteroid is orbit
of the asteroid and its orbit by
astronomers as well as new radar
observations using precise orbit
analysis at an estimated
1 000 feet in diameter the asteroid was
set to veer close to the planet in 2029
later assessments pushed that back to
2036 and then to
2068 now there's a high degree of
confidence among
astronomers that there is no chance of
it impacting earth and now they're
saying that we have about 100 years
probably
we don't have to worry about any
asteroids hitting the earth and
destroying all mankind
and i know you probably feel exactly as
i do when i read this and it and
that is sorely disappointed this is the
this is the worst news
we've gotten in weeks this one this was
our
this is this was the escape plan we
always had that asteroid
any time i saw you see a little little
nas x's video you see that you think
well look at least we got the asteroid
put us all out of our misery not anymore
we gotta wait a hundred years
that's too bad okay uh a bonus here
i also wanted to mention this before we
get into uh youtube comments and daily
cancellation
just because it gives me a chance to
speaking of youtube it gives me a chance
to plug
some content on on youtube i did a
review of addison ray's
new pop single on my youtube channel
which you can go watch
if you don't know who addison ray is
well then you're in the boat that i was
in about three days ago before i did the
video
but apparently she's a tick tock star
who
now uh is a pop star she came up with
this pop song
um and she went on um the tonight show
to promote this song and do a little
dancing and now she's in trouble here's
the la times
reporting they say many of tick tock's
viral dance
challenges were started by black
creators but
you wouldn't know that by watching
friday's episode of the tonight show
which saw one of the app's biggest stars
addison ray performed several dances
without crediting their choreographers
what was intended as a fun moment
between rey and host jimmy fallon
who were both white backfired over the
weekend as twitter users demanded
recognition
for the people whose choreography was
featured on the show so she did some
racist dancing i think we have the video
let's just play some of the video here
of uh so you can see what this racist
dancing looks like from addison ray can
we play this
okay and they just now
[Music]
they're they're going through and doing
these different i guess these are all
viral dance challenges and she's going
through and doing all these
these dances which
first thing is i don't watch late night
shows at all
but um aren't they supposed to be funny
is this is this supposed to be a funny
gag
she's dancing so it is kind of funny
because she's so bad at it
[Music]
that's the most shocking thing to me i
don't know anything about this woman
but now she's a pop star a lot of a lot
of fans
[Applause]
but with pop stars you expect them yeah
the music's gonna be terrible
uh but you expect them at least to know
how to dance and this to me strikes me
as really bad dancing
and the third point i will make here
just watching that is um
we could turn this off okay that's
enough of that the jeans that she's
wearing
so she's got these what are these the
mom jeans really baggy
holes in the jeans and i guess is this
this is the style now
i don't want to bring up we're not
getting into the skinny jean
conversation again i'm only saying i'm
not advocating for skinny jeans don't
accuse me of it
i'm only saying what is happening right
now the
i guess this is what the kids are doing
now the super baggy
jeans with holes in them you know and no
i i'm not going i
we i live that life okay we as
millennials we we've done that we've
been there
we did that in the 90s
can we i guess my only question is
can we as a society i know we can't
agree on much we can't come to
very many compromises on anything but
can we
sit down and have a conversation and
figure
and and and settle on one style of genes
i don't understand why it has to change
drastically every eight years
can we settle on one style something
really basic boot cut
whatever i don't know why we can't do
that
um and i you know when i was a kid i did
think the baggy jeans
style was you know fashionable but
looking at it now it looks
completely ridiculous okay let's moving
on to uh move on to reading the youtube
comments
this is from big mac he says all we have
to do is argue that you should need a
vaccine passport to vote
and watch how quickly the left will
abandon the idea
that's that is that is an interesting
point
now i i hope that by the time we get to
voting even in 2022 we're not still
having this conversation about vaccine
passports but uh you know that might be
optimistic so we'll see we'll see how
they handle that
um kade says matt blinks too loudly so
his wife retaliates by putting syrup in
the fridge i love this marriage
that's closer to the reality than you
than you might think
um aaron peacock says hey matt just want
to say thank you for this
podcast i believe you're one of the most
important voices of our time
so many will roll their eyes because you
choose to talk about statues being torn
down trans story hour and pre-k
and the garbage on tick tock but i
believe these are huge cultural topics
that need addressing thanks for being
unashamedly a christian unabashedly
conservative and unashamedly man oh and
the beard is looking grisly
no cap my guy everything was going
so well aaron towards the very end there
when you're teetering on is it very nice
but you're teetering on the edge of
getting banned now
with a phrase like no cat i don't know
what that means no cap
grizzly no cap my guy is that all one
expression or is
um katie lee says speaking as a pale
girl am i being discriminated against
with band-aids too
the shade is far too dark for me this
goes both ways there are plenty of
latinos asians and arabs
with that skin tone as well yeah we
learned yesterday that um
a teacher on tiktok was talking about
how another example of white privilege
is that band-aids only match white
people
and i did have the same thought on top
of everything else how stupid the it is
in general um band-aids are generally
darker i think than most white people
right
um and another comment says wait wait
wait you said
you said raised in homes without fathers
then you automatically go straight to
black children as if other races don't
have this issue as well
screw this dude yeah no
i i think i mentioned that the
fatherless home problem
is increasingly a problem across the
country
in all communities and i think
i i think the number is like 30 percent
i could be wrong about that
generally in america but you also can't
get around the fact that in the black
community the fatherless home
uh figure is 70 more than 70
and if you narrow that down to the inner
cities it's even higher than that
that is that's those those are
catastrophic numbers
okay the numbers in the white community
for followers home
those numbers are really really bad but
70
is catastrophic and so
yes we need to talk about that even if
it is uncomfortable
finally joshua says here's my
relationship advice don't listen to
people who say a marriage takes work
if your relationship takes work move on
if you truly cared about and accepted
your spouse for who they are
you shouldn't have to work to like each
other i have to say joshua that is
the worst marriage advice i have ever
ever heard if it takes work
move on terrible advice
and i'm not going to ban you from the
show because i think you need to you
need to keep watching so you'll learn a
few things
hopefully you're not married or i assume
if you if you were married you weren't
married very long with an attitude like
that
no um yes a marriage does take work
anything worth doing
takes work parenting takes work
yes it does require work you have to
work on yourself
you have to work on your relationship
you have to do it you have to do work
in the house we do all kinds of work
that's part of life
anything um that you can derive real joy
from any any source any potential so
source of true joy and happiness and
fulfillment and contentment
is going to require work as well
i the only thing the only credit i'll
give you
is uh this may apply
a little bit to non relationships
so if you're only dating and you find
that the relationship requires a lot of
work even there
where it's still very new and
you're you know you're not you're not
married yet you don't have that
commitment you don't have a family
yet and you find you've been dating
someone say for like three months
and it requires a lot of work to keep it
going then yeah
okay there i would say cut ties and move
on
three months into a dating relationship
it shouldn't require a whole lot of work
so if you're doing work already then
yeah i think there's a good time
send a quick test text message that's
all you got to do and say listen this
isn't working out and uh and go your
separate ways and it'll be fine
you'll forget about each other in a
couple months but marriage is a
different deal marriage requires work
for sure
and as conservatives we all say that we
value the constitution
we value our second amendment rights but
how many of us have taken the time to
study these issues how many of us have
taken the time to learn the skills that
we need to defend
our rights and our liberties well my
friends over at constitutioncoach.com
have a lot of great programs for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying and living out the constitution
i experienced myself the constitutional
defense course
and this is something you have i can
tell you about and i have but you've got
to
experience it on your own you get an
amazing combination of intellectual
ammunition
and live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and then
you also get the physical training at
the premier firearms training facility
in the nation
you got to see this place by the way
it's very impressive you get all this in
the same course okay
you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation for a
time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people whether you have you know if
you've shot guns your whole life or if
you've never touched one if you're
somewhere in between whatever it is i'm
telling you
these people took me to an entirely new
skill level
and they're gonna do the same for you
guaranteed so go to
constitutioncoach.com
with all the instability in the u.s
these days you don't want to wait to
learn these skills
rick and the constitution team um have
another class on april 25th but it's
going to fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today and watch my
video there to find out more
about how you could be a part of this
one-of-a-kind training at
constitutioncoach.com
now as you've probably heard candace
joined the daily wire a few weeks ago
with the premiere of her new talk show
candace the show streams on
dailywire.com fridays at 9 00 pm eastern
8 pm central but you can get the audio
podcast candace on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcast
candace hosts a series of guests on the
show each week
making for lively panel discussions and
insightful interviews as well
featured guests have included jocko
willink brandon tatum
uh john rich and also this week i'll be
on the show
most important thing of all if you can
if you can't attend the show in person
you can tweet your questions to
at the candace show for a chance to have
candace answer your questions at the end
of the show
so if you need some candace owens in
your podcast feed look no further head
over to
apple podcast or spotify and subscribe
today and also remember to become a
member so you can watch
the whole show dailywire.com
code candace now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we're going to cancel a teacher in
virginia's
loudoun county public school district
though really we could cancel the whole
school district itself as it
is a constant source of exactly the sort
of lunacy
we're going to discuss today as the
daily wire reports quote video footage
shows a virginia public school teacher
bullying a student for saying that he
takes a colorblind approach to observing
people
school teacher in virginia's loudoun
county public school district one of the
wealthiest districts in the nation was
caught on tape telling a student
that it's important to see racial
differences when observing people
for a class assignment the teacher
posted a photo of two females one with
white skin and red hair another with
black skin and black hair students were
asked to observe what they saw in the
picture
one unnamed student responded by saying
he saw just two people chilling
the teacher called the student
intentionally coy for not categorizing
the women by their race
okay let's let's actually we have the
audio of that moment let's play that now
the story behind this picture um i'd
rather
hold on to that that's coming with what
this seems to be a picture of it's just
two people chilling
right just two people that's nothing
more to this picture
no not really just two people chilling
i don't believe that you believe that i
don't believe that you look at this as
just two people
um i don't think truly is just two
people though is it not
yeah but i think you're being i think
you're being um
i think you're being intentionally coy
about what this is a picture of what
are you being coy about it's two people
standing back to back in the picture
yeah and that's all you see is two
people i i'm confused on what you would
like me to
to speak on that i don't think you are i
don't know why you do this
um i'm not trying to call you out but
you could you you
you know you come out off of mute to
talk about what this is a picture of
and you act as if as if you know there's
nothing
noticeable about this apart from the two
people
well i'm confused are you trying to get
me to say that there are two different
races in this picture
well at the end of the day wouldn't that
just be feeding into the problem of
looking at race instead of just
acknowledging them as two normal people
if we're
going for let's say if we're looking for
equality within all this then why would
we need to point
out things such as that because those
things those differences are real things
a few points to make here first this is
what brainwashing sounds like in real
time the only difference between that
and most public school brainwashing is
that in in this case the student had the
wherewithal to resist it
now consider that most kids not even
kids but all people adults do
don't really possess the critical
thinking skills and backbone necessary
to defy
a perceived authority figure in that way
and they especially are incapable of
thinking and acting for themselves
when the issue at hand is something as
toxic and emotionally charged as race
and racism
because the implied threats and
sometimes over alert threat of course
is always if you don't agree with me and
adopt the correct views
you will be racist most people cave to
that threat very easily
because in our culture today being
called racist is the that is
the worst thing you can be labeled even
worse than being labeled like a
pedophile to be
to be labeled a racist is the worst
and most people will cave to it
immediately now for kids
you can't blame them when they cave
because they're just kids for adults i
do blame them
yeah that doesn't stop them from doing
it also notice the nature of this
brainwashing right
the students they're not just being
taught
to believe something like to believe a
certain proposition
to accept certain facts to remember
certain bits of data
rather they're being told how to think
the teacher is telling them how to see
other people think about that he wants
to change the way
they fundamentally view other human
beings
and he wants to do this because he
subjectively personally
thinks that people should see other
humans this way
this is apparently how he sees other
people judging them by their race first
and foremost
and his mission now is to get the kids
uh their kid the kids brains to work the
same way
that his does he's like a it's like
imagine a schizophrenic
insisting that his students must all
learn how to hear voices in their head
like he does
it's quite disturbing to think about and
even more disturbing when you consider
that millions of students encounter this
kind of mental conditioning every day
and as we established most are not going
to be able to withstand it
second point there's a great irony in
this exchange
i believe that the girls in the picture
are named lucy and maria ailmeyer
the only reason i know i know the name
is that they're a relatively well-known
case of twin sisters
who appear to be different races they
have a white father and a
jamaican mother this is a rare instance
where twins with interracial parents end
up individually resembling the race of
one parent or the other
but of course those girls are the same
race
they have the same genetic ethnic mix
just manifesting itself differently on
the outside
the point is that the student was more
right than he realized
he saw them as two people he didn't see
them initially as two different races
or at least he wasn't focused on that if
he had said oh i see a black woman and a
white woman
he would have been wrong he would have
been judging them based on their
appearance
and it would have led him to a false
conclusion so he avoided the false
conclusion by not focusing
on outward appearance and that's what
got him in trouble with the teacher
the teacher was mad at him because he
wasn't wrong
he said that 2 plus 2 equals 4 and the
teacher yelled at him for not saying
that it equals five
third point finally this relates back to
that sesame street clip we played last
week not the one with the little nasdaq
there's been a lot of sesame street
related content on the show recently
sesame street introduced some black
muppets whose job is to teach
four-year-olds about critical race
theory gone are the days of cookie
monster teaching that c
is for cookie you know they won't even
let the poor guy have his cookies
anymore because of the obesity
epidemic in any case in the clip
the puppet says that what's on the
outside is what makes us who we are
this is the same message that the
teacher in the video is trying to hammer
home
but this not only directly contradicts
what we were all taught growing up
and not only encourages exactly the kind
of racism that they're supposedly trying
to prevent
but it also of course flies in the face
of every single thing they say about
gender
if what's on the outside makes us who we
are
then wouldn't a penis make you a man
if if you're supposed to notice
somebody's race and find significance in
it
then shouldn't we notice their sex and
find significance in that
well apparently not we've learned that
at least in the confused mind of the
modern left
that that even though your biological
sex is more ingrained and more immutable
than your race
still somehow your race is this
changeless identifying characteristic
while your sex is fluid ever-changing
and ultimately inconsequential
is totally incoherent but that's part of
the point
you're not supposed to understand you
are supposed to simply accept
and obey and even if you don't believe
it at least pretend you believe it
this is the message especially in the
school system
and it's why you should think twice
before sending your kids into it
especially the loudoun county school
district in virginia which in any case
is now canceled and we'll leave it there
for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
joe biden wants a new round of mask
mandates christie gnome won't go all the
way to fight gender ideology and
guatemala teaches the u.s how to deal
with caravans of foreign nationals check
it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]